you know a couple years ago maybe more
than that at this point
i uh i was asked to be in a political
commercial
and uh it was it was a little too much
for the uh
for the focus groups it was a little a
little edgy so
didn't see the light of day then but
this has been repurposed into a
commercial that i think
not only fits in with the tenor of 2020
certainly fits in with the tenor of
today's show
these are the stakes of the election
five months in office and democrats are
in full control of washington d.c
i'm not on a timetable i'm on a mission
kamala harris cast the tie-breaking vote
confirming six new supreme court
justices today we have a chance
to change the course of history kovitzar
andrew cuomo tells us about severe new
penalties for democrats
implement free health care for all
illegal immigrants where is joe biden
the president hasn't been seen in public
for three weeks
it's washington's worst kept secret that
kamala harris is calling the shots
washington's newest parlor game is who
will be kamala's vice president
it doesn't have to be this way there's
still time to stop the zombie apocalypse
that's basically what we're talking
about and the zombie might not be
all of us you know it might not be like
actual
zombies where you gotta like shoot them
right in the heart and they're coming
around they're just eating you
it's a zombie constitutional order it's
a zombie country it's a zombie
mainstream media apparatus it's a zombie
educational apparatus it's it's a zombie
country
that has been hollowed out from within
deprived of its vitality that is now
staggering along kind of looks like joe
biden while it's staggering along
are we going to preserve the life of the
country or
are we going to let it get sucked out
even more potentially if the democrats
get their way
such that conservatives will not have
the opportunity to win at the national
level anymore
which is what they are openly explicitly
promising
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts